why is the Church of the starry wisdom
named as such in H P Lovecraft's 1936
story titled the hunter of the dark the
starry wisdom cult also called the
Church of the starry wisdom used in
ancient relic The Shining trappers of he
dream to summon a being known as the
hunter of the dark for unlimited
knowledge of the universe he demanded
terrible sacrifice the church is called
the starry wisdom because these people
were literally receiving wisdom from the
stars from Nyarlathotep one of the outer
God's in A Song of Ice and Fire
Melisandre here is the whisperings of
the flames re on damp hair hears a voice
from the waters the children of the
force sing the song of Earth someone has
to speak for the stars according to
ancient myth the bloodstone Emperor
brought about the long night when he
usurped his own sister he was said to
have set aside his old gods to worship a
black stone that had fallen from the sky
he was said to have practiced all manner
of Dark Arts which included torture and
necromancy most importantly he was
claimed to be the first high priest of
the Church of the starry wisdom it seems
as though the bloodstone Emperor
encountered some Lovecraftian type being
and made a similar knowledge in exchange
for sacrifice deal to the one the Church
of the starry wisdom made in the
Lovecraft story the Haunter of the dark
throughout the song of ice and fire
books danny has received messages from
Quaithe in the forms of dreams and
apparitions quaithe provides scenarios
with prophecies and cryptic instructions
one of the most famous of these
prophecies which is repeated several
times is to go north you must journey
south to reach the west you must go east
to go forward you must go back and to
touch the light you must pass beneath
the shadow so what do these cryptic
instructions mean first we have to
decipher a why quite is speaking to
Daenerys at all
based on several threads of evidence I
have come to the conclusion that Quaithe
is a part of a larger organization whose
shadow operations have global
implications i'm talking about of course
the Church of the starry wisdom in a
sidebar in the world of Ice and Fire
according to the annals of ash I the
Valyrians were given dragons by a people
from a place called the shadow who were
so ancient they had no name
these mysterious people also taught the
Valyrians who were nothing but goat
herders at the time all the legendary
Valyrian magical knowledge before the
doom of Valyria happened danny's the
dreamer whose name is quite similar to
Daenerys had a premonition of Valerius
fate because of this vision House
Targaryen was saved 400 years later and
Daenerys seems to be a spiritual
successor today knees Daenerys also has
prophetic dreams but as I said before
Daenerys extremes are likely from
quaithe who also tells scenaries that
she is from a place called the shadow
Koide seems likely to be from the same
shadow as these ancient people who
taught the Valyrians magic and it also
seems as though these ancient ones
likely sent the vision to danny's the
dreamer that foretold the doom of
Valyria to go even further it seems as
though Quaithe has done with Daenerys
exactly what the ancient shadow people
did through Danny's dreams Quaithe gave
her instructions on how to birth dragons
the ritual was laid out in Danny's mind
though she did not fully understand why
she was doing what she did
so if Quaithe is a part of this group
from the Shadowlands what suggest that
this is the Church of the start of
wisdom to understand this we have to
look at the language Martin uses when
quaithe is communicating with Daenerys
in Danny's final dream in a game of
Thrones before she wakes knowing that
she must light the pyre George our
Martin gives us this line after that for
a long time there was only the pain the
fire within her and the whispering of
stars
she woke to the taste of ashes the
whispering of stars that phrasing
suggests start a wisdom because Danny is
hearing a voice from the stars and after
which she wakes with knowledge of
birthing dragons she is literally
receiving starry wisdom in a dance with
dragons when quite the Pierce didn't
Ares we get this sequence she dreamed
all her cares fell away from her and all
her pains as well and she seemed to
float upward into the sky she was flying
once again spinning laughing dancing as
the stars wheeled around her and
whispered secrets in her ear to go north
you must journey south to reach the west
you must go east to go forward you must
go back to touch the light you must pass
beneath the shadow Quaithe Danny called
where are you Quaithe then she saw her
mask is made of starlight again here
Daenerys receives wisdom from the stars
in a dream Danny floats into the sky and
dances amongst the stars
cuase mass itself is made of star light
again Danny receives knowledge from the
stars
so if quake is tied to an organization
the started wisdom seems like the best
bet right now
so if quate is from the Church of the
story wisdom where is the church and
what does it want as far as where it is
the obvious answer is the shadow by a
shy and this is not just because this is
were quite claims to come from but also
because this is the place where Miller
Sandra has visited take another look at
that quote from Daenerys his dream after
that for a long time there was only pain
the fire within her and the whispering
of stars
she woke to the taste of ashes if that
sounds familiar to you then you are not
mistaken this is for Milla Sandra a
dance with dragons the fire was inside
her an agony and ecstasy filling her
searing her transforming her seeing was
never as simple as those words suggested
it it was an art and like all arts it
demanded mastery discipline study pain
that to roll or spoke to his chosen ones
through blessed fire in a language of
ash and cinder and twisting flame that
only a god could truly grasp Daenerys
speaks of pain and fire within her when
she wakes she is transformed and has the
strength to do things she never imagined
Milla saundra also mentions that relora
spoke to his chosen few through a
language of ash and cinder and twisting
flame Danny wakes with the taste of
ashes in her mouth and when she steps
into the pyre the fire takes on magical
characteristics and becomes almost alive
in a way that is quite similar to Milla
Sandra's visions in the fires the flames
were so beautiful the loveliest thing
she had ever seen each one a sorcerer
robed in yellow and orange and scarlet
swirling long smoky cloaks she saw
crimson fire lions and great yellow
serpents and unicorns made of pale blue
flame she saw fish and foxes and
monsters wolves and bright birds and
flowering trees he
more beautiful than the last she saw a
horse and a great grace stallion limed
in smoke its flowing mane a Nimbus of
blue flame further Milla saundra is not
only a red priestess but a shadow binder
as well same as quaithe and according to
the world of Ice and Fire
it is only shadow banners that have the
courage to venture up River into the
heart of darkness in the shadow we have
quaithe acting as an agent to the Church
of the starry wisdom who are based in
the heart of darkness in the shadow we
have Daenerys who is receiving messages
from the starry wisdom which fill her
with fire and transform her through pain
we have Milla Sandra who is also
transformed through pain but instead
receives whisperings from the fire but
at the same time
Melisandre has Tyus to the shadow
because she is a shadow binder with
knowledge that no other in her order
possesses could it be that while Milla
saundra thinks she is in communication
with rule or she is actually in
communication with the starry wisdom the
church obviously works in ways which are
difficult to understand but if they
could directly make things happen from
afar Quaithe wouldn't simply give
Daenerys subtle clues she would tell her
exactly what to do instead quaithe is
only telling Daenerys exactly what she
needs to hear at certain times but there
are still two lingering questions what
does the Church of the starry wisdom
want and what do cuase cryptic
instructions mean in the beginning of
this video I mentioned the bloodstone
Emperor who legend tells us start at the
Church of the started wisdom he too
received knowledge from the stars
seemingly from some being that came from
the sky some entity that fell with the
black stone and lives through it
I think this being still remains and in
fact lives at the heart of darkness now
we have to figure out how much of quoits
instructions are literal and how much
are metaphorical the first part to go
north you must journey south to reach
the west from Moscow east
could be considered as literal assuming
Westeros is a round planet either
direction eventually would lead to its
opposite to go north you must journey
south could be taken figuratively as
well in Danny's final chapter in a game
of Thrones north and south are compared
to Ice and Fire
they laid them north to south from ice
to fire that being considered quaithe
could be telling Daenerys that before
she can fight the others she must
complete her transition into a true
dragon this interpretation also adds
weight to Quaithe imploring that
Daenerys remember who she is and
suggesting that the Dragons still do at
the end of a dance with dragons the
second part of the instruction to go
forward you must go back and to touch
the light you must pass beneath the
shadow seems to me to suggest that in
order for Daenerys to succeed with her
destiny she must learn the knowledge of
the past she must go back and in order
to touch the light this knowledge she
must pass beneath the shadow she must go
into the shadow lands and into the heart
of darkness so those are quite cryptic
instructions to Daenerys but there is
still the final question what does the
Church of the starry wisdom and the
force they worship want it would seem
that the Valyrians delivered the wrong
version of history
dragons did not originate in the 14
flames but in the shadow where they have
never stopped existing only this
explains why brand saw dragons start in
the east in the beginning of a Game of
Thrones
it has claimed that the bloodstone
Emperor's started the long night by
killing his sister but ultimately what
evidence is there that he was as evil as
they say in my opinion the evidence that
we have suggests that the children of
the forest started the long night when
some faction of them broke off and
besieged a cold power in the north this
power brought the winter and gave them
strength that they never had before
turning them into the others the frozen
she as George R Martin called them all
of this would have had to have happened
around the same time that the
Stone Emperor was said to take the
throne from his sister and worship a
stone from the sky which gave him
knowledge I put forth that the
bloodstone Emperor did not start the
long night but in fact ended it if you
are familiar with my grand game theory
and you can probably already see the
threads of where this is going a force
in the north that gives power a black
stone in the Far East that gives
knowledge the cold God that turned the
children into the others gave them the
power to create a winter that never
ended and a darkness that covered the
globe this was felt everywhere
perhaps whatever spoke to bloodstone
through that stone told him how to stop
it told him how to end the long night it
told him how to fight the cold and dart
through fire and light the very same
light that Daenerys must touch beneath
the shadow
I believe that bloodstone went to the
shadow found a dragon and became the
first dragon rider he then used this
dragon to stop the others which marched
out of the gray waste I speculate that
bloodstone flew east and north and ended
up at the tip of Westeros from there his
dragon would have literally been light
bringer fire from the sky a river of
flame coming out of the darkness
burning the dead saving humanity Danny
will do the same she will pass beneath
the shadow and finally understand her
purpose her dragon will be Lightbringer
come again and she will be the savior
from the north the starry wisdom cold
speaks for an entity and has a
preference for fire and the others speak
for an entity that is opposite to that
one so in a sense
milah Sandra's religion is correct but
even she misses the fact that this is in
fact a game
and has always been a game larger forces
using smaller forces as pawns this is
the hierarchy of their reality and
therefore a perfect contrast to the game
of Thrones
what does the Church of the starry
wisdom want to win hi guys thanks for
watching this video if you like this
channel feel free to subscribe and also
please like the video if you want to
support this channel please consider
checking out my patron I also want to
get a special thanks to two patrons in
particular wkc and training girl every
one of my supporters is greatly
appreciated and I couldn't do it without
you thank you so much
[Music]